I call this your money autobiography and
as a money coach this is the first step
I take with my clients
think back to your earliest childhood
money memory
what did it feel like when you got money
were you excited proud or confused
and what did you do with the money did
you run to the candy store or did you
run to the bank
and what did you hear your parents say
and what did you see your parents do
with the money
change is difficult
but in my family not changing is fatal
so I did the work and I have experienced
deep and profound forgiveness
it only takes one person and your family
to break through the money shame cycle
I want you to be the one